[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele von euch haben uns um ein video
gebeten in dem durch erklären was ist
eigentlich mit diesem kommunismus auf
sich hat und heute liefern wir es euch
wenn du visual politik schon eine weile
erkennst weißt du wahrscheinlich dass
wir mit der kommunistischen seite des
politischen spektrums nicht besonders
stark sympathisieren wir denken vor
allem aber dass man sich bevor man sich
eine meinung über etwas bildet vorher
doch ein wenig informieren sollte oder
na dann mal los
[Musik]
am ende dieses video seht ihr sogar
sehen dass es durchaus ein paar
praktische dinge gibt die ihn mal aus
der ideologie von karl marx gewinnen
kann und von denen er sicherlich
überrascht sein werden
nun wir alle kennen jene internet rolle
für welche die ideen von marx entweder
einen heiligen gral darstellen oder aber
absolutes teufelszeug
dabei haben diese leute meistens so gut
wie gar nichts von oder über marx
gelesen
sie tragen einfach nur mehr oder weniger
zutreffende stereotype über den
kommunismus mit sich herum bevor wir
beginnen muss ich euch aber darauf
hinweisen dass dieses video nur eine
zusammenfassung der idee von karl marx
und friedrich engels ein fast in zehn
minuten können wir nun mal nicht die
ganze geschichte des kommunismus oder
gar das wird irgendwann da diesen
geklärt ist lasst uns anfangen
das erste was er wissen müssen und das
wird für viele von euch eine
überraschung sein ist das meist ein
materialistischer denker war das heißt
er dachte die hauptmotivation des
geschichtlichen und sozialen wandels
seien materielle güter die grundlage des
marxismus ist es festzustellen welche
güter mehrwert haben als andere aber sei
gewagt wir sprechen hier über den wert
nicht den marktpreis letzterer kann
durch andere dinge wie steuern oder
monopole beeinflusst werden die
marxistische theorie formaxx wird der
wert einer ware durch die arbeitermassen
die für ihre herstellung erforderlich
ist ein beispiel wie viel ist dieser
stuhl wert es wäre die summe der
arbeitsstunden des schreiners dahin
hergestellt hat aber auch die des
holzfällers der den baum stellte des
schnees der die nägel anfertigte und so
weiter und so fort
alles in allem also die ganze arbeit
aller menschen die am produktionsprozess
dieses stuhls beteiligt waren zweitens
ist es aber auch sehr wichtig das
konzept der kapitalistischen ausbeutung
zu verstehen dieses hat nichts mit den
arbeitsbedingungen oder lohnhöhe
stell dir eine montagelinie in eine
automobilfabrik vor mit 100 arbeiter
laut max ist der hier generierte
wohlstand die summe der arbeit dieser
100 menschen aber diese menschen
erhalten dafür nur einen teil der
wertschöpfung die sie durch ihre arbeit
schaffen
der rest ist gewinn der dem eigentümer
der fabrik gezogen
[Musik]
das bedeutet wenn die arbeiter acht
stunden am tag schuften bekommen sie
vielleicht nur das ergebnis der ersten
drei oder vier stunden arbeit
der rest also das was der unternehmer
einstreicht nennen wir den mehr gerate
des mehrwerts ist daher der exakte
ausdruck für den explorations grad der
arbeitskraft durch das kapital oder des
arbeiters durch den kapitalisten also
fragst du dich vielleicht dieses möglich
dass der eigentümer die arbeiter so
leicht ausbauen
warum bekommen die arbeiter nicht den
gesamten wert den sie erarbeiten
die antwort lautet das geht erst mal so
gar nicht denn sie brauchen ja werkzeuge
um die ganzen rohstoffe in eine
nützliche sache zu verwandeln außerdem
benötigen sie eine fabrik einer
werkstatt oder weitere gebäude
dies alles wird im jargon der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler als
produktionsmittel oder investitionsgut
bezeichnet und derjenige dem dies alles
gehört als kapitalist im rahmen dieser
definition ist es max vollkommen egal
wie reich jemand an konsumgütern ist
denn trotz allem was einige leute denken
hat max da kein problem damit wenn du
eigentümer eines luxuriösen autos oder
eines maßlos überteuerten handys ist
seiner meinung nach steht das
grundproblem erst wenn du
produktionsmittel wenn eigen nennen will
das heißt besitzer oder teilhaber eines
unternehmens wirst warum aber wenn er
gerade das zu extrem schädlich
[Musik]
die widersprüche des kapitalismus marx
teilt die gesellschaft in zwei klassen
auf der einen seite stehen die kapital
ist die bourgeoisie laut max
kontrollieren sie den produktionsprozess
und leben von der ausbeutung der anderen
klasse
das sind die arbeiter oder proletarier
diese produzieren nach marx den
eigentlichen wohlstand und bekommen
trotzdem nur ein paar krümel davon
zurückhalten
deshalb so marx befinden wir uns in
einem ständigen konflikt dem sogenannten
klassenkampf von dem hast du vielleicht
mal gehört und genau diese konstellation
sei die uhr sünde der kapitalistischen
marktwirtschaft
wie ihr seht hat das wir magst nichts
mit armut oder gleichheit zu tun
in den skandinavischen ländern zum
beispiel in denen die unterschiede
zwischen reich und arm relativ gering
sind herrscht dieser definition zufolge
auch kapitalistische ausbeutung da dort
ebenso privatbesitz an der produktion
von waren beteiligt ist daher greift max
mit seiner kritik nicht nur die
kapitalisten an sondern vor allem auch
die sozialdemokraten
[Musik]
eine zweite weniger systematische und
mehr praktische form des sozialismus
suchte der arbeiterklasse jede
revolutionäre bewegung zu verleiden
durch den nachweis wie nicht diese oder
jene politische veränderung sondern nur
eine veränderung der materiellen
lebensverhältnisse der ökonomischen
verhältnisse ehe von nutzen sein können
zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen dass
die arbeitsbeziehungen im kapitalismus
darauf basieren dass eine gruppe von der
anderen ernährt wird
dies nennt marx die infrastruktur des
kapitalismus damit diese jedoch
funktionieren können brauche die branche
war sie eine geheimwaffe die ihre
vorherrschaft garantiert zu diesem zweck
schufen die kapitalisten eine geeignete
regierungsform gesetze kultur und sogar
religion
all das wird in marxismus überbauen
welche lösung aber bietet max nun an um
mit dieser ungerechtigkeit ein ende zu
bereiten
die proletarische revolution
[Musik]
die kommunisten verschmähte es ihre
ansichten und absichten zu verheimlichen
sie erklären es offen dass ihre zwecke
nur erreicht werden können durch den
gemeinsamen umsturz aller bisherigen
gesellschaftsordnung weiter erklärt max
dass der kapitalismus nicht nachhaltig
sei er sagt sogar voraus dass als erstes
die großen industrienationen fallen
insbesondere das vereinigte königreich
was zur marktzeit das industrieland
nummer eins
sie hat nicht nur die waffen geschmiedet
die ihr den tod bringen sie hat auch die
männer gezeugt die diese waffen führen
werden die modernen arbeiter die palette
ja und jetzt kommt das ironische an
dieser ganzen geschichte
wenn wir einen blick in die geschichte
werfen stellen wir sofort fest dass alle
länder in denen marxistischen
revolutionen dann tatsächlich
stattgefunden haben kaum
industrialisiert waren und eigentlich
auch keine nennenswerte branche was die
aufwiesen
es waren länder wie russland oder china
dort hatte sich ein kapitalistisches
wirtschaftssystem nie wirklich etabliert
zumindest nichts das wollen markt
bestehende aber es kommt noch besser
in ländern mit einem weit entwickelten
kapitalistischen wirtschaftssystem fand
nie auch nur eine einzige politische
revolution statt im gegenteil den
industrieländern ungarn der
tschechoslowakei oder ostdeutschland gab
es revolutionen gegen kommunistische
regierung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und diese waren vor allem durch
ausländische besatzungstruppen an ihm
aufgekommen
tatsächlich lautet die schlüsselfrage
die alle marxistischen philosophen
zumindest in westeuropa im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert beschäftigte warum verdammt
noch mal haben wir noch immer nicht jede
revolution die macht uns versprochen hat
wenn ihr euch wirklich für den marxismus
interessiert sind einige dieser
philosophen eine lektüre wert ich
empfehle euch diese autoren wenigstens
mal an zu lesen insbesondere jürgen
habermas oder antonio gramsci
untersuchen auf faszinierende weise die
funktionsweise von sprache und die
realitätswahrnehmung des menschen und
deshalb bietet der marxismus ungeachtet
dessen wie er wirkt tatsächlich einige
interessante erkenntnisse die auch in
weniger marxistischen bereichung
anwendung finden können zum beispiel im
marketing aber das wäre schon wieder ein
thema für ein weiteres video schreibt
uns in den kommentaren ob es euch
wirklich interessiert wie einem axis
muss bei einer marketingkampagne
weiterhilft
der autor des spanischsprachigen kanals
von visual politiker hat tatsächlich ein
ganzes buch über dieses thema
geschrieben aber auch spanisch wenn du
ein wenig spanisch verstehe ist kannst
du es dir unter diesem link ansehen
es heißt marxistisches marketing für
nicht marxistische politische partei und
jetzt ist es an der zeit mir eure
meinung zu sagen
glaubt ihr dass die theorien von karl
marx in der heutigen welt noch immer
relevant sind
lass mir eure gedanken hierzu in den
kommentaren zu kommen vergesst nicht
dass wir jede woche neue videos
hochladen werden und verpasst keines
unserer updates indem ihr einfach
unseren kanal abonniert und wenn euch
dieses video gefallen hat die uns auch
einen daumen hoch macht's gut und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]